الارتفاع نحو 150 مترا يقف جبل الدخن في
منطقه منبسطه ومنفرده عن باقي الجبال في
محافظه العرضبي منطقه جازان في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هذا الجبل نسجت حوله
الكثير من الحكايات الغريبه وحتى الاساطير
ليصبح معلما سياحيا بارزا من معالم
المملكه فهو من الاماكن المفضله للمغامرين
والمحبين رياضه تتسلق الجبل محاط بالاماكن
الزراعيه الكفيفه ويتكون من تشكيلات صخريه
ضمن منطقه سهليه مليئه بالاشجار والثمار
والتي جعلتها من المناطقيه المفضله
للسياحه
[موسيقى]
ومن الجزائر وتحديدا من جبل دق من ضم
الينا مراسل صباح العربيه اسامه القاسم
اسامه اهلا بك خذنا في جوله في حول الجبل
الاساطير كما يوصف واحد اشهر المناطق
السياحيه الكبرى في المملكه
اهلا وسهلا سهام تحيه طيبه عليك وعلى جميع
مشاهدين صباح العربيه بالتاكد اليوم اقف
امام احد اكبر جبال محافظه العارضه بمنطقه
جازان والذي يتجاوز طوله ال 150 متر
وتجاوز عرضه 2000 متر مربع هذا الجبل يعد
من احد اشهر الاماكن السياحيه والتاريخيه
في العارضه قد يعود عمر الاكثر من 5000
عام هذا الجبل ايضا مهم جدا لرياضه التسلق
الهايكنج وايضا حتى حفلات الشباب ومكان
سياحي كبير جدا كان يقع في منطقه زراعيه
كثيفه جدا عن مستوى الزراعي وايضا هو يقف
ويقع بالقرب من سد وادي جانا الزميل خلف
المطرف الان ياخذنا في جوله حول هذا الجبل
لان تتعرف اكثر على تاريخ هذا الجبل كما
سبقت سهام هذا الجبل يعود عمره لاكثر من
خمسه الاف عم به عدد كبير جدا من النقوش
والاثار والكهوف رؤيه عنه الكثير من
الاساطير والحكايه وهذه الاساطير الحكايه
كما سبقت هي همم موضوع انشائي ليس له اي
همم علاقه
علميه او حقيقه علميه وارده ويكاد لا احد
يجهل هذه المنطقه سهام يعني اي احد يجي
العارضه او حتى جيزان بشكل عام يعرف هذا
الجبل كونه من احد اشهر الجبال الموجوده
نظرا لاختلاف تشكيله ان هو ليس مستقيم
فحسب انه هو متدرج على مناطق زراعيه كثيفه
ايضا بها عدد كبير جدا من الاشجار النادره
والتي تكاد لا توجد الا في هذا الجبل
احدها احد هذه الاشجار يستخدم في تطعيم
الشاي وايضا احدهما يستخدم في ادوات طبيه
هذه المنطقه ايضا هي منطقه همم سياحيه
كبيره جدا كما سبقتها منطقه همم منطقه همم
زراعيه بشكل كبير جدا اللون الاخضر يكتسي
هذه المنطقه من الخلف ايضا واتمنى لو اني
همم نستطيع ان نريكم الجانب الاخر هو ايضا
اكثر اخترارا لكن خلفيه الجبل ليست توضحه
كما هي الان هذا الجبل كما سبقت سهام همم
كل همم الموجودين في هذه المحافظه وحتى في
منطقه جيزاني كادوني يعرفون هذا الجبل
يعني من احد الطرائف انه الشيبان زمانه
كبار السن اذا يبون يخوفون الاطفال او كذا
يقولون بنوديكم اديكم لانه مكان مظلم في
الليل همم يعني ولا توجد به اي مظاهر
الحياه سابقا فكان الاطفال يرتعبون من
موضوع الدكما الان لا اصبح الان منطقه
سياحيه كبيره وشهيره جدا كما اسبقت ما احد
في هذه المنطقه تقريبا يجهل هذا المكان
كونه ارتبط بالسياحه كونها ارتبط ايضا
بالزراعه كونها يقع ايضا بالقرب من سد
وادي جازان اي واحد يشوف ايضا الجبل وايضا
اي واحد في الجبل ايضا يشوف سد وادي جازان
طيب انه كان يخفوا الاولاد لانه على حسب
الاساطير او تزع من الاساطير انه هذا
الجبل تحديدا يسكنه الجن بداخله بحيره
تحرسها حيه كما تقول الاساطير وتزعل طيب
اسامه المعروف انه هذا الجبل
هواه متسلق الجبال هل بالفعل هناك قبال من
قبل الشوفين بتسلق الجبال
[موسيقى]
كما سبقت سهام هي مجرد اساطير وحكايه ليس
علاقه
كل الدراسات الاثريه والتاريخيه لم تذكر
هذا الموضوع بالنسبه لرياضه التسلق
تشاهدين الجبل اساسا مهيا لتسلق الجبال
الان هذا الشهر والاشهر الثلاثه القادمه
ما هي اشهر الشتاء في منطقه جازان همم
سيشهد كثافه كبير جدا من المحبين التسلق
رياضه
هذا الجبل ايضا همم صحيح انه ارتفاع 150
متر لكن الوصول اليه صعب وبالتالي هو يشكل
تحدي كبير جدا
لمتسلقين الجبال وحبيبين هذه الهوايه هم
يستخدمون ايضا لانها منطقه سياحيه ومنطقه
ايضا خضراء وبالتالي هم ما يستهدفون
الموقعين انه انا امشي في منطقه خضراء
ومنطقه همم بالاكسجين وايضا اصعد الجبل في
كوريا رياضه واحده في مكان واحد همم مسطح
بشكل كبير يعني اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
انجازات على هذه الجوله من الجبل مراسل
صباح العرب العربيه شكرا لك اسامه القصير